let me show you how you can use some of
these i'm going to
start with some results that you already
know the answer to that we can work out
without identities
so that you can verify these answers for
yourselves okay
have a look at them don't shout it out
but just think
that's an easy one that's super easy
this one is not quite as easy but we can
work out what this is we already have
the tools for this one
i just want you to have it mentally
farther away in your brain so that when
you get to the answer you'll be like aha
really does work let's give this one a
go for the sake of illustration
how could we express this in terms of
the identities we already know
fantastic all right let's do that sine
60 plus 30. so here's my
a plus b okay being that
i'm sine a plus b here's
you can just as easily do 45 or 25 you
can do other anyway
you could i mean you could do 90 and 0
if you really want but you know it's not
that interesting
uh in fact i've welcomed you to do
strong 45 plus 45
right because you will get there
differently to us but you'll
get the same thing all right let's
unfold this let's do the identity right
so it's going to be sine
a cos b
read it out to yourself plus cos
a sine b
there we go okay and we know what all of
these are
okay sine 60 that's going to be root 3
on
2 cos 30
is also root 3 on two so it's just
squared
do you agree with that then you cross
over here cos 60
a half side 30 also a half
yes right is that coincidental
in math nothing is coincidental okay
root three and two
or squared that's three quarters
a half all squared one quarter
so it's one just like you were expecting
right now
i won't write it down but just for the
sake of illustration right again
if i had made 45 plus 45 then all of
these angles would be all 45
right but sine 45 and cos 45 are the
same
angle in fact that's double angle isn't
it right so if i went
actually i will write this down if i
went to double angle and said okay it's
equal to
sine to
a where a is 45 degrees
i would write that as 2 sine 45
cos 45 tell me what's side 45 what's
called 45 same thing
one on root two so when you're one over
two times one root two you get
a half which is times two
right you see we know this we expected
it it works okay
yeah this one's a bit trickier it's a
bit trickier but
you know what it equals to right second
quadrant it's cosine think about it
related angle
okay that's exactly right so let's get
there and let's show it
by these identities we already know what
kind of angles would you like me to pair
up
with 60 i think is a good
choice you could just as easily have
gone
180 minus 30 okay
and then done the expansion from there
but usually when you do these we're
looking for an acute or right angle
okay because they're the ones we tend to
know exact values for right
okay expansion for cos a plus b
cos a cos
b is it plus or is it minus
minus sine a
sine b yes okay
now let's just go through the whole
thing because the substitution step is
important
even though i know what this first term
is going to become cos 90 is zero
right times uh-huh
right minus sine 9 is 1
and sine 60 is root 3
on 2 which is minus root 3 on 2
which we should have expected because
that's minus
cos 30 degrees because i'm in the second
quadrant so cos is negative
okay so see how it all works now these
answers we knew them already we need
them already
but these identities they allow us to
try questions where we don't know what
they're going to be
and in fact we will find their exact
values
exact values for everything okay
what angles can we use yeah what do you
oh sorry
yeah 45 degrees minus
30 degrees okay so excuse me
it's the same as this expansion but
because i've got a minus there
cos doesn't match up the sides so i'm
going to get plus in the middle
cos 45 cos 30
plus sine 45
sine theta okay
so cos 45 sine 45 they're both the same
one on root two
cos a through three or two
okay psi 45 i've already stated that
and inside 30 we know is a half
now you will see you'll notice that the
denominators are the same
so i can combine these fractions quite
easily right i'm just going to get root
three plus one
on that i could rationalize but there's
not a huge amount to gain all right
there's the answer it's an exact value
for something
that we didn't know exact values for
before but as you can see because of how
many combinations this is going to open
up
there's no point memorizing this okay
especially when it's so easy to get from
the expansion
yeah um can you is it possible with like
more than two angles in the side or like
do you just not well all right so so
yes and no so uh we memorized the
well you will memorize the double angle
formulas okay
uh if you think well if i could double
an angle i can also triple it or
quadruple or do whatever i want
right now you don't you're not expecting
to memorize any of those
but they're not that hard to establish
for instance let's let's
do it over here cos of three theta
positive three theta okay i don't have a
triple angle formula but that's okay
because because of that that there i can
write as an a plus b
right as two different angles i guess i
would write it as oops
sorry i would write that as theta plus
two theta
yeah okay so now what happens i'm going
to use my regular
cos a plus b identity so i'm going to
get
cos theta cos 2 theta plus or minus in
the middle
minus minus minus because the sides
don't match up sine theta
sine 2 theta and if i so chose
i could go further than this right
because i'm going to have
this guy here which would be cos squared
minus sine squared
minus and then over here that's going to
become
2 sine theta cos theta so summarizing
that
there will be two signs in there and a
cos
okay now that's a bit of a mess but
but what i do here this is going to be
okay there will be two
sine theta cos theta so the sine thetas
go together
which could be sine squared and the cos
squared is just cos theta sorry it's
just hanging out over here
or negative sine theta
is that it is there
i don't get it okay i'll do i'll do it
again with another line
and we're not that smart okay i'm going
to substitute out
sine two theta for its identity this is
the double angle again it says 2
sine theta because theta okay
so since i'm since i don't want to skip
steps i'll do something in here while
i'm waiting
see here right i started with cosine
right
so it would be nice if i ended with all
cosine zero if at all possible
and i can really much right this in here
right can become one minus cos squared
right so this will become cos theta
cos squared minus watch out there's this
sign so that'll become that
oops sorry
do you see why because the minus sign
out the front okay so close the bracket
and then here i mean there's a two
that's the only number so throw it out
the front
this side and this side will become sine
squared
because okay
so i can keep going i'm not done yet i'm
not done yet right for starters i can
see i have a cos theta
outside everything right there common
factor is that okay
so i'm going to write cos theta out the
front
okay now in here what's happening i've
got
cos squared plus cos squared so i'll do
that
okay and then what's going to be left
over here minus 2. now instead of
writing sine squared
i want to get everything in terms of
positive so 1 minus cos squared
there and i've already accounted for
that cos way over here keep going
right so i can keep going right uh in
fact
okay i'm running out of space so forgive
me right minus two times one
minus minus two right and then minus two
times this
will become plus two
so i've got a cos theta out the front
then i've got
four of these cos squares
minus three yay and that's pretty much
as far as i can go there's no simpler
you can get that's equal to zero
so there you go so that's of here that's
right so for instance if it's cos three
theta equals zero then i can solve that
right it's a bit of a mess i mean but
you know i